la parole est à monsieur yves albarello
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
monsieur le premier ministre je souhaite
vous interroger sur le projet de loi
droit des étrangers actuellement en
cours de débat dans l'hémicycle
nous l'examinons au coeur de l'été en
procédure accélérée
n'est ce pas la volonté du gouvernement
d'éviter au maximum les débats ce texte
est un véritable appel d'air à
l'immigration illégale
je souhaite aborder un point précis qui
concerne la seine-et-marne
en effet une commune de ma
circonscription il vous plaît le mini
l'âme l'eau possède un des plus grands
centres de rétention administrative dans
votre texte
une des dispositions parmi les plus
dangereuses concerne les clandestins ou
les étrangers en situation illégale pour
eux l'assignation à résidence devient la
règle et la rétention administrative
l'exception autrement dit on va leur
demander de bien vouloir ne pas changer
l'adresse mais c'est de l'angélisme que
d'y croire êtes vous assez n'est assez
naïf pour penser qu'anne étrangers en
situation illégale ne changera pas de
domicile et attendra gentiment qu'on
vienne le chercher pour le reconduire
dans son pays
le résultat sera à coup sûr de rendre
les mesures d'expulsion encore moins
applicable aujourd'hui cette disposition
si elle devait voir le jour fera
certainement le plaisir aux passeurs et
aux trafiquants qui exploitent la misère
des cinq cent mille clandestins
installés en france
mon ami et collègue guillaume larrivé
propose que la rétention administrative
passe de 45 à 180 jours au royaume-uni
aux pays-bas la rétention administrative
est limité à 18 mois
six mois c'est un délai minimum pour
organiser avec les pays d'origine
les retours de leurs ressortissants
cette situation compliquera le retour
des clandestins en rendant plus
difficile leur placement dans les
centres de rétention administrative sur
ce point monsieur le premier ministre
vous me donnez le sentiment d'être
contraint de céder face à la gauche de
votre majorité
ma question est simple allez vous
revenir sur cette mesure d'assignation à
résidence qui sera inapplicable dans les
faits
et dangereuse dans ses conséquences la
parole est à monsieur bernard cazeneuve
ministre de l'intérieur monsieur le
député depuis le début de ce débat sur
la loi relative au séjour vous répéter
en boucle des choses fausses
comme si vous aviez reçu instruction de
le faire à chaque instant j'ai une
petite idée d'ailleurs de la personne
qui vous a donné l'instruction de
manière à donner le sentiment qu'il y à
issy la responsabilité et la le laxisme
alors je vais vous donner quelques
chiffres
oui mes tableaux dit c'est pas trop vite
parce que vous pourriez être déçu je
vais vous donner quelques chiffres
extrêmement précis pour ce qui compte
c'est qu'on cerne les reconduites
forcées à la frontière qui sont la
véritable marque de la volonté d'un
gouvernement de résister à l'immigration
irrégulière l'année pendant laquelle on
a le moins expulsé deux migrants
irréguliers c'est en 2011 le chiffre en
2012 était de 13 milles
il est aujourd'hui de plus de 15000 nous
expulsons plus de migrants irréguliers
que vous ne le faites parce que nous ne
considérons pas qu'il y as d'un couple
de l'incompatibilité entre la nécessaire
humanité et la fermeté c'est à dire que
vous êtes très fort dans les discours
vous faites beaucoup de rhétorique et
quand on regarde les résultats
il saute éminemment médiocre le deuxième
point sur lequel je voudrais vous
rappeler un certain nombre de réalités
c'est sur la lutte contre l'immigration
clandestine et la démantèlement des
filières de l'immigration irrégulière
depuis 2012
nous avons démantelé 25% de plus de
filières de l'immigration irrégulière
pourquoi monsieur le député et bien tout
simplement parce que quand on se re
supprime 13 mille emplois dans les
forces de sécurité on a une police de
l'air et des frontières qui n'est pas
capable d'assumer ses missions et bien
le mini le premier ministre lorsqu'il
était mise de l'intérieur à augmenter
les moyens de la police de l'air et des
frontières
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
des résultats vous êtes dans la
rhétorique vous êtes dans l'outrance
vous est dans la malle gamme
nous nous avons choisi d'être dans
l'efficacité
merci monsieur min